how many of you
are currently netflix subscribers
ooh nice
how many of you actually use some kind
of stream processing or even processing
system
in production nice okay a lot of you
guys
so i think let's get started
so just like any any specific uh domain
of problems that you're trying to solve
uh it acquires a certain terminology
there are certain patterns of all over
time and uh
the field of dealing with unbounded data
processing is no different
so i'll go over some of the terminology
some of the concepts how to deal with
unbounded data processing we look into
existing stream engines
i'll cover three there are a lot more
out there
and then we'll look at what we are doing
at netflix to handle these
challenges at scale
so we'll start with getting to know our
terminology
the first thing that we observe is
how we describe the data right today
we talk about streaming
to mean a couple different things we
mean it's an infinite stream of events
that are flowing into our system
and we also use it to refer to like an
execution engine
so for example you may say i'm using
streaming data or i'm doing streaming
analytics
but at the same time you might be
referring to the kind of processing it's
doing underneath the hood
uh maybe storm maybe flink or you may be
referring to
you know batching to mean spark
and the same thing with batch you may be
using it to mean couple different things
you may be using it to mean a bonded set
of data or events that are flowing into
your system
or you may use it to mean the
type of execution engine that's handling
that data
so you know let's let's be precise about
our terminology because it's going to
make a difference of how we address
certain things when we're talking about
it
uh let's use unbounded to mean
an infinite set of data or events that
are flowing through
and bonded to just being the finite set
and we can use streaming and batching to
mean whether
at the core the engine is streaming or a
batching engine
so we could say streaming
a streaming execution engine can handle
either bounded data
or it can handle unbounded data set or
and
the likewise for batching right so for
example with hadoop you can actually
not only do real-time data by just
segmenting it
and it's been done for quite a long
period of time you just segment into an
hourly boundary and then you kind of
deal with one hour chunk
data at a time and you could do the same
thing with streaming you could take
a finite set of data like a file and
make it look like a stream and process
it that way
so whether it's streaming or batch both
those engines can handle bound or
unbounded data once we have the clear
terminology
so you may ask how do i choose a certain
processing engine so the three factors
you need to consider
when you want to choose one you have to
choose between the trade-offs of latency
cost and what kind of accuracy you're
looking out of your system
and you should choose an engine
that lets you make these trades off but
does not make it for you
so you need to have the option open for
a use case you can choose between these
three
and make a wise decision
the next important aspect is processing
semantics of your events that are
flowing through
you care that you want to process every
single event that's flowing through a
system
if you're doing metrics and you just
want a ballpark understanding of what's
happening
maybe a point one percent or one percent
of drop really doesn't matter
but if you're doing uh like billing and
you're doing ad clicks and you want to
charge back to your customers
the accuracy really comes in the picture
and you don't mind paying the extra cost
to get that accuracy
and we have the notion of exactly one
semantics
quite often this is misunderstood as
exactly one's
delivery which is very different and
very
impossible to achieve practically if you
think about it
so what we mean by that is let's say you
let's take a simple example let's say
you want to add three numbers together
you add the first two numbers and your
system crashes and when you recover back
again
you don't want to add the first two
numbers again so for example if you're
adding two plus two plus two
when you come back up from a failure you
want the answer to be six not eight
right so if you do at least one
semantics you could get eight
if you do at most once you could get
four but if you exactly want
every single time you should get six
provided your
source is repeatable and you're able to
replay from it
so when it comes to accurately
processing your batch data
it's relatively easy because you know
the data set the data set's not changing
and all you're doing is wasting a little
bit of time because you're reprocessing
it
let's say it took four hours to process
it you have to reprocess it again
you take that extra amount of time but
when it comes to
an unbounded data source things are a
little different
it's because your data is moving forward
in time and you don't have an infinite
buffer to hold it forever
you want certain consistent guarantees
between failures so you cannot
start over a 12-hour job all over again
and start from beginning
and the reason you may be doing the
real-time process
processing is because you want that
result early enough and not have to
wait for it if it crashes so you need
a way to capture consistent state so
that when it fails you can resume from a
good
checkpoint and the other thing you need
is if you want to do some kind of
aggregations and groupings
you have to group your unlimited or
unbounded data into smaller chunks
right there's no way around it so you
need good tools to reason about how do
you group that
how do you deal with late data how do
you deal with
um you know errors in the system so
there's two really important concept
when it comes to
unbounded data stream processing
the time the notion of time associated
with event is
really important as well broadly you can
think about it as three different times
associated with an event
even time is when the event is actually
created
and a timestamp that's associated with
it
ingestion time is relative to your
stream processing engine when it enters
into the system
your system assigns a timestamp to it so
that you know what time you actually
ingested the event into it and that
ingestion time kind of remains
constant throughout your processing and
the last one is processing time that's
the time in your
computation operator or your engine
actually sees that
so if you have a digraph of operations
that you connected together
each one will see it at a different time
because everybody is not getting it
at the exact same time
so let's look at the simple example to
better understand uh those three
concepts
so you have uh some kind of iot sensor
that's emitting events and you're
capturing those events
and assigning time stamps to it so
that's your event time
and it makes it way through maybe a
queue or messaging buffer like
kafka and it enters into your
processing system and there's an
injection time assigned with it
there are different use cases for it so
for example you may just
worry about i just want to know how many
requests per second i'm getting into my
processing engine
through my job graph right so ingestion
time is a good way to know that
versus you want to know you know what's
happening on the sensor in the last five
minutes you know how many
sensors did it emit or how many events
did it emit
then you want to go by the event time
otherwise your accounts will be
inaccurate
so if there are ten events that were
being generated in a five minute time
span
but it took eight minutes to deliver
because of network issues
uh or delay uh then if you just
say in this five minutes what did i get
you'll get the wrong answer because you
missed the other events that came
late so if you do it by event time then
you get accurate
results
windowing we talked about being able to
group
and make your unbounded dataset bounded
so you can do operations on it
and usually you don't need it if you're
just
operating on an element by element basis
so for example let's see all you're
doing is filtering and you're not doing
anything else then you really don't need
windowing because
you don't need a group of things to work
with
but if you do want to do a group of
things
like you know aggregation or you want to
group by your accounts on some or
average then you need to bound your
unlimited stream
otherwise you'll be buffering that data
set forever and
will run out of resources to do any
meaningful computation on it
so the trend of two broad classification
of windows
one is aligned and unaligned with align
windows what we are saying is
if you take a view into your unbounded
stream
then everything in that unbounded stream
belongs to your window and you can have
multiple windows into that
view with on the line you're picking and
choosing
out of it so like tumbling windows
sliding windows would be aligned
because you're taking fixed chunks of
your data
in everything that's in that chunk
you're using it for processing
versus something like session windowing
you're picking and choosing which
events fall into a certain window
so let's look at an example so in this
use case we have an unlimited
stream of events flowing through we have
some that
come late in time some arrive right in
time
so we have an event that's
occurring between 12 and 1 pm
and even time actually was between 11
and 12.
and for the second one it was between 12
and
uh 1 pm so
we see here that the event that we
picked
out into that window and all of the
events that fall into 11 and 12
will fall into that window right versus
if you look at something like
sorry let me go back to the sliding one
first so we had the tumbling window
where we have clear
boundaries between the two windows and
there's no overlap that means an element
is not included in two windows at the
same time that overlap
and if you have a gap between the
windows so for example here these are
one hour windows and
let's say the second window started 1105
instead of 11. now we have a five minute
gap there
and that's called hopping windows so you
can sometimes use it for sampling your
data set
and you when you don't want to process
the whole stream
uh the next is overlapping like sliding
windows so for example you can say
every minute give me a count of the
requests that are coming into my system
right so you kind of every minute you're
looking at the events and you may
recount the events that fall across the
boundaries
these this is the example of underlying
windows the session windows
as you can see between the first 10 to
11 o'clock
the events that are in our input stream
are actually being grouped into
multiple session windows uh so it's not
symmetric it's not aligned with the
input so that's what's called in
unaligned windows and you'll hear this
in in different literature so it's kind
of good to keep in mind uh when you hear
these terms
uh so let's uh look at triggers
um now you've grouped your unbounded
data set
when do you figure out you want to
compute the results on it right we just
grouped it right now
so triggers help you determine that when
exactly you want to
compute results out of it so it could be
before you decide that
my window is complete so for example if
your window is
an hour long you don't want to wait for
that whole r before you get the results
you want to get a quick peek into it so
that for operations you can make sure
everything's fine
so you could say every five minutes you
know whatever you have just compute the
results and show me so i can see
progress
that's happening and so that's kind of
before window and then you can say when
it's
the r boundary give me results or emit
the results
or i could say do it later so for
example
you could get an event at 1205 and
you've already computed your window for
11 to 12
and you get one more extra event you can
roll that back into your sum later on
so the triggers kind of determine when
you actually
emit the results and computation of a
window
so let's look through a concrete example
when you land on a netflix home page you
see a list of movies on the bottom
and we want to compute you know how many
times somebody clicked on a certain
uh movie box art
so it makes it easier to think about it
in in in four questions
uh right so what is it that you really
want to compute
in this case we're interested in
computing the counts per movie id
and where that means you know
what's your timeline or time boundary
and event time that you want to compute
it over
and you're saying every four minutes i
want to see how many
people clicked on this certain movie and
uh i want to trigger the results every
two minutes so i can see the progress of
what's happening and
make a dashboard out of it right and
last thing is if i'm getting late events
how do i deal with it
so let's have a partner downstream and
i'm sending them the sum
and i said okay in the last 1r i saw 100
clicks on this one
but because a mobile device was off
somebody's on the plane they got off and
then we got an event really late
and if you cared about accuracy if you
take that
event and add it back and say oh sorry
it's not 100 it's actually 101 that you
saw
later on so the last question kind of
determines what do you do
when you get late data and how do you
refine your results
so there's an important notion of
watermarks
now if you looked at grouping a window
but
we could get events later right so how
do we
determine that a window is complete uh
we need some kind of notion of
completeness
even if you say we're going to add that
event back later there still needs to be
some kind of
notion of completeness so watermarks are
used for that
they usually lag behind the event time
and in an ideal situation you'd be
processing an event as soon as you
see it in your system and if you were to
graph that it would be like a straight
a diagonal line as you see in here
but that's not really the case in
practice
it varies so here's an example
we have one stream where the events are
in order and we have the next stream on
the bottom there where the events are
happening out of order
uh on the one on the top we say we are
emitting these water marks
um as the events are flowing through our
system
and we say okay we've limited watermark
20 that means we are sure that we are
not going to receive anything
after 20 and it's okay to do the
computation
up to the elements that included 20. and
these numbers are
timestamps it's assumed like a
sequential time stamp
and on the bottom when it's out of order
you can see that you get elements
element 20 before you get 19 and your
watermark says
my window is going to be up to 17 right
so it gives you kind of
a way to describe what the lateness is
or
completeness is about your system
so when you plot in practice
this situation you see that there's a
skew between the ideal
and when you actually actually generate
the watermark
because your watermark will always be
lagging behind there's a lag of getting
that event when it generated
into your system due to several network
reasons
or the devices offline so when you
actually
look at the completeness of it it's
going to be skewed from the
from the ideal line and
if you compute the water marks too slow
then you'll be holding a lot more data
in your memory before you flush it out
and move on with your computation if
you're too fast you'll miss some events
and you'll have to deal with those
events later so it's not
a perfect it's a heuristic watermark
that you build out
and then you still have to worry about
how to deal with uh delayed events
so um working with late data
in a in a real-time stream processing
system and if you want accuracy it's one
of
the quite challenging things to do
especially when you're emitting
results downstream you don't know if the
downstream sync is unimportant
what kind of side effects it's having so
it makes it challenging
to build accurate systems when you have
late arriving data
so everything i talked about has evolved
over time this is a great paper to read
it's evolved from systems like millwheel
flume java
and many other older systems and the
terminology has evolved over time
and this paper gives a nice overview of
how to
not only have a programming model but to
reason about these things
and apache beam which is incubating is a
kind of
a programming model an abstraction and
they have a runner which you can target
your
generic apis onto a certain engine like
spark or fling
so let's quickly review what we looked
at right we looked at
how do we add time support or
what kind of time support do we need in
terms of even time injection time
and processing
um time windowing we looked at
watermarks
um how do we deal with state and
uh checkpointing checkpointing is really
useful for recovering from failures so
every so often
uh the the system could create a
checkpoint uh both for metadata
about your system so for example if
you're consuming from kafka then you
need to remember your offset
in your stream and at the same time you
may be operating and creating
counts you also want to store those
counts and that's the data
so when you checkpoint both the metadata
and the data and you have a failure you
can recover from it and have exactly
one's processing semantics
okay there you go um
so in addition to those basic
functionality um
a lot of these frameworks also offer
transformation
functionality like map filter groups
joins
and it also allows you to specify a
complex digraph of your job and it takes
care of computing it
and it also supports different events
and sources and things
and some of them make it easier to even
launch jobs by supporting some variation
of
sql you know it's generally called
streaming sql
now that's not all you need in an
operation system to put it in production
you need a lot more than that you need
to make sure the system's stable and
handles back pressure when there are
choke points in your system or a sink is
getting slower or your source is getting
slower
your system shouldn't keel over and die
it needs to handle the back pressure
you need a way to manage your job code
that you're running
and the life cycle of it you may or may
not have
you know no downtime requirements so you
need to take all those into
consideration
you need a multi-tenant environment if
you're running a lot of these jobs
and the computation is varied you want
to maximize the resources
so you want to make it run in a
multi-tenant environment
you need auto scaling you need dynamic
rebalancing of workers
and you need a way to quickly push your
code out into test and prod and run it
against
shadow data to see what's happening so
as important is the as important as the
programming model is
and the functionality of framework
provides it's equally important to
pay attention to the operational
features uh associated with that
streaming engine
because that's what's going to decide
how stable your system is going to be or
not
so let's look at what uh runtime
and uh execution engines we have at our
disposal to deal with this problem
uh at a high level if you were to you
know do a back of the
napkin design of it you'd end up with
something like this
you need uh something to buffer your
events so that in in
in the event of your producer going away
in the event of failures in your
processing system
uh you have a way to get back to your
data so you don't lose it
and you can use systems like uh kafka
kinesis pub sub you name a system that
works for you
and then you have the execution runtime
with all the operational features that
you talked about in multi-tenancy
and then you have the execution engine
itself that supports you know the notion
of event time windowing and watermark
and things like that
and the other important aspect of this
is if you have a stateful job
you also need a good way of dealing with
state
if it's a large state you know how do
you deal with it ideally
so what you found is if you have a
system that supports local state that is
backed off to remote state that works
the best
because you're not constantly going over
the network and looking up remote data
it's available locally when you need it
and when it fails you can always recover
it back
from the backup store
how many of you are familiar with kafka
and how it works
okay quite a few so i'm going to skip
over what it does
but in one line it lets you have a
partitioned
set of it lets you partition your topic
and you can send events into those
different partitions and you can consume
it
as a queue or if you have multiple
groups you can consume it as a pub sub
topic
so let's look at samsa and how it works
uh internally
so samsa has an interesting philosophy
this is related to 0.9
they have a single threaded model for
actual processing
but for fetching the data they have a
multi-threaded
approach so for example let's say you
have four partitions that you're
processing in one sam's a job
it launches four threads it pre-fetches
the data
and it holds it in memory so the
processing is much faster
the processing itself happens on a
single thread and it goes through three
steps it goes through process window and
commit
and during the window you can set how
often you want the window to trigger so
it's a pretty
simple timer just think about it as a
you started a java timer or something
and then
it fired so that's your trigger that
we're talking about so every 30 seconds
it's going to give you a call back and
you can decide what you want to do
and in your comment it says okay you i
did the processing that you asked me to
do
now committed so in that situation you
could
take a kafka offset that you read from
and you could store it in a store
so that next time when you resume from a
failure you know which offset to start
reading from
so comment lets you come at your
position uh in the stream
and gives you an opportunity to
checkpoint your state as well
and that's both the local state as well
as the metadata about where you are in
the stream
so here we see that as the state changes
the local state let's say
let's come back to our count click
example you're accumulating the cons for
different movies
and it's stored in a local state
and it flushes that state to another
kafka topic which it
treats it as a change lock stream so
it's very much similar to
the event sourcing pattern there where
every single change is emitted into a
change lock stream
if you fail it's going to read the whole
chase lock stream again the problem with
this is if you have really large state
and you have a lot of updates on it then
your change lock stream is going to be
really big and your recovery times are
going to be very large
um so you've seen that that if you're
you know upwards of one gig two gig it
takes a while for it to recover from its
call state
and if you want to hook together a job
graph
in samsa you have to you actually have
to connect them
with topics in between so you have to
create the cuff topics
you have to link them up for each job so
it doesn't take care of automatically
running
a complex digraph for you
you have to manually hook it up so it
looks very much like a set of
architecture there and
there's a lot more work you have to do
they are working on some enhancements to
make this
easier but 0.9 didn't have it
so let's
let's see what was missing out of
samsara right so we didn't have any kind
of event time support
out of the box that it's supported
there's no way to do any watermarking
out of the box
you have to build all that functionality
in it
and from a runtime perspective it's kind
of a single threaded blocking model when
it does io
so you could assign it one core in a
multi-tenant environment if you're
running you know like a docker or a
meso-style environment
but again when you're doing i o the
resources are left unused
so they're changing this model slightly
and they're going to add
support for multiple threads so they can
leverage those resources better
so it's spark streaming
how many familiar with spark streaming
okay a few hands good so the
idea behind spock streaming is it takes
the input stream
and it actually chops it up into smaller
batches
so it does micro batching and batches
below a second
below half a second have a lot more
overhead and we'll look at
why that's the case in a second so it
chops it up into smaller
uh pieces and then it processes each
piece
so it's not exactly like windowing you
may think it kind of looks like
windowing but it's just micro batching
up front and what your results are also
kind of
results of those micro batches
so spark uses a notion of rdd so rdds
are
to say briefly their collection of
elements that are distributed across a
cluster
and they're partitioned so every rdd
could have multiple partitions and you
can do operations on it in parallel
and rdd is also when you do
transformations and rdds they also
record the lineage of it
and the rdds are immutable so once you
create an rdd and you apply
transformations of it you get new rdds
and this lineage is captured so that
when there's a failure then how to
recompute it back because everything is
mutable
and they just apply functions over it so
it's the functional programming
aspect of it that's leveraged quite a
bit there to make it happen
so in this case we see we have rdds for
each micro batch
and we have some operations on it and
then you could do some kind of windowing
on it by grouping a couple of batches
but then it has to happen around the
batch boundary
right so if you say my micro batch is
one second then you can do your windows
in multiples of those
uh batch sizes you cannot have an
arbitrary window size
it has to match your batch size so it's
kind of a limitation
spark 2.0 they have experimental support
for event time
it's not fully out there yet and it's
not deployable in production but you
could you could take a look at the
initial support they have for event time
but currently they don't have it that
you could use it in production
and spark uses a notion of d stream
which is nothing but chunked up
rdds right so
the streaming is still micro bashed and
they just call it this
discretized stream or d stream
um so for efficiency
what happens here is if you see the four
small rectangles in a bigger rectangle
these are all individual rdd partitions
and i've kind of overlaid to concepts
here so
let me explain to make it easier um
you could have let's see you could have
map and filter and flat map
that you're sorry if you let's say you
have map and flat map that you're doing
it in
in your job spark can take a look at
that and say
okay map and flat map i don't have to
cross network boundaries to those
operations
it's going to change those operations
together and launch it on one single jvm
and it's going to apply that to a
certain partitions of rdd so it can do
that operation in parallel
across all the partitions of an rd that
are spread across your whole cluster
so that's what it's doing here like it's
doing a map a couple of maps and then
it's doing a radio by key at the end of
it
spark 2.0 has something called
structured streaming they just have more
explicit data types and they've unified
how you do
the api programming through data frames
and data sets
and looks more like sql so you can write
one style of code
and you can apply it to both streaming
and batch side of the world
so they have a planner it's very much
like a like a database where they have a
planner
it creates a logical plan and at the end
of the day everything gets converted
into rdd operations so this is an
abstraction that sits on top of rdds to
make it simpler
for you to write jobs and this just
shows how it
how the planner is incremental as well
and it needs to figure out how to
match the micro batching architecture as
well
so when you actually deploy this in in
production
uh you have a few components in in place
one you have the
cluster manager that you're launching
this in it could be something like
marathon or meso so that you can launch
the driver program
the driver program kind of works like a
coordinator it's managing what's
happening
on the worker nodes and the tasks that
it gets assigned so if you have a job
graph it needs to determine
which jobs need to go first and don't
have a dependency so it does kind of a
breadth for scan
schedules those jobs in production when
they're done
it takes the results back feeds it into
the next set of jobs and it schedules
those jobs
now it's sparked because it's micro
batching every micro batch let's say
you're doing
500 millisecond micro batches every 500
milliseconds the number of events it
received it's going to put it in a batch
and let's say you have five different
operations you're doing on it
it's going to schedule that on the
cluster and every schedule
and and every micro batch results in a
new scheduling
so you're paying a little bit of
overhead there although it's pretty fast
but if you lower your micro batch size
you pay that overhead of scheduling
every time
now they do have what's called executor
java process that's running on all these
hosts so it's not a complete cold start
it does have uh the jvm upper running
but you're still making that scheduling
call over the network and trying to get
the job up and running
so we looked at with spark
they currently don't have full back
pressure support
what happens is every click or time
click so let's go back to the micro
batching example of
half a second so every half a second in
its
scheduling queue it's going to schedule
an event saying okay i want you
to schedule this job onto the cluster
and regardless of what's happening to
your processing and how slow it is
it's going to keep adding that event
into the scheduling queue so it's never
going to stop
so as your scheduling delays build up
let's say you have a problem with your
sync
or there's a node that's bad in the
cloud and
it's taking longer to compute then the
back pressure builds up
your scheduling queue keeps growing
forever and eventually you'll run out of
memory
right and so we have this problem in
production for some of the jobs we're
running
so we have a monitoring job that looks
at scheduling delays and kills the job
in these other jobs right it's not ideal
so the back pressure support we've
worked with the community to get the
back pressure support in it
it's not fully there yet uh there are i
think a couple more jiras left to
uh be completed there for the full back
pressure support to get in
uh and the back pressure support is more
like a a pid
it's like a feedback loop from control
systems so it's not completely
automatic you still have to tweak a few
knobs to make it happen
so flink is another new
stream processing engine it's streaming
at the core
unlike spark it's not batch based it's
actually true streaming based
and it can handle both streaming uh
sorry you can handle both bounded and
unbounded data
so let's take a an example here so this
would look pretty much similar to
the apis and functionality we have on
the spark side right
you have all the same kind of operators
available to do
map and flat map and go groups and
updating state
and flink also takes care of
automatically managing the state that's
associated with each operator
and it also takes care of checkpointing
that state and
creating backups of that state so
it creates a point in time snapshot
of your data associated with each
operator
and also what's happening to your input
stream and it stores all the metadata as
well
so it actually offers exactly ones
processing semantics out of the box
spark does that as well by the way with
rdds and the lineage
it uh holds on to
so we see here another example of how uh
pipelining is happening
very similar to the spark api we looked
at so they're pretty similar
in that format
the way they get scheduled is kind of
similar instead of having
executors you have something called task
managers here
and instead of the driver program you
have something called the job manager
with coordinates uh what's happening on
these nodes
they have a notion of task slots which
is similar to the tasks you saw
in spark streaming
and this this one shows the state that's
being accumulated for
um each operator uh which is stateful
uh so this goes into a little bit more
into detail about how actually flink
does its checkpointing and
so you have the job manager what happens
is
the job manager inserts barriers into
the streams that are flowing
and these barriers actually don't block
your processing that's happening on the
different nodes
what it does is it lets the processing
on that node
align to the barriers so that when
barriers from two different streams
it will wait for those to align once
they align it will trigger a checkpoint
and these checkpoints you can have a lot
of checkpoints in flight because none of
them actually block your processing
which is the best part
and when it when the two streams are
aligned with the barriers
it creates a checkpoint and sends an act
back to the job manager
the job manager records that checkpoint
and also takes a
a snapshot of the state of the operator
so if it if the job were to fail at any
point in time it can exactly recover a
point in time where you left off so it
does that out of the box
it has a really nice support for
something called something called save
points
very similar to the database so when
your job's running you can issue a
command and say
create a save point for me and then you
can take that save point and either
start
a new code provided it's compatible
or you can run another job starting off
that state so you can do
a graph of very much like git you can
take the state
and then spawn off into different
branches and run your processing through
it
so either you could use it to do a b
testing or you could launch a canary in
prod and say
is my new job actually going to be able
to successfully
start off where this job leaves and so
you can do all that kind of testing
without even
touching your existing job that's
running so save points are pretty
powerful
in letting you do those kinds of things
so we talked about how do we do
you know like analysis and real-time
analytics on the streaming jobs and
unmounted data
the one thing that i'd like you to kind
of consider or question is
are there any applications that you
write today and you have to write a lot
a lot of custom code for it which could
have fitted into
a streaming model and when we look
harder the quite a few problems we look
into
where we could actually apply this model
so it's another
you could think of it as another pattern
or an architecture to build your
applications out of
so let's see what we are actually doing
about this in our production
um my team deals with three large areas
we have messaging as a service which is
where kafka falls into place
via stream processing as a service and
we have something called a management
service that helps us manage
our infrastructure across all these
systems and automate the critical
parts of it so we can scale without
having to scale
people and our philosophy is to create
reusable functionality so people can
quickly build
their applications on top of us so we
might have
you know libraries to do anomaly
detection we may have libraries to do
some kind of specific processing that
makes it easy to use
for others and we help curate these
common functionality
across different groups
so let's let's see what scale netflix
runs at
the background picture you see actually
is a is a real store with that name in
berlin which is really surprised to see
so netflix is available pretty much
globally today and it's it's the world's
largest streaming network
and we have over 83 million subscribers
um enjoying our shows on you know
thousand
plus different kind of uh devices and
they're watching over 125 million hours
of video every day
so they watched a portion of it while
we're sitting here and and
watching this talk so this leads to
about a trillion events that gets
processed in our pipeline every single
day
and about 1.4 petabytes worth of data
flows through it
we have peaks of 16 billion messages a
second and 43 gigabytes a second
a data volume that's flowing through it
and we do all this with four lines of
availability
so we have steadily grown the number of
events we've seen
in relation to the subscriber base that
has grown
and we've had to evolve our system over
time uh
we we inherited an old system that we
replaced earlier this year
which is what we'll dig into a little
bit more deeper
so this is the uh a snapshot of our
management layer where the users can log
in
and let's say they want to start
generating events
so they create a new data stream and
what that does is it automatically
provisions a new kafka topic
based on uh the ballpark estimate that
provided us
of what the traffic could be and then
the link of what the sync should be
they can declaratively specify what a
filter is kind of looks like a json
path filter and when they say provision
we just provision for them we launch it
in a multi-tenant environment running on
docker containers
and they're up and running so it's uh
stream processing is a service but the
functionality is
limited in what they can provide
and by default they automatically get a
dashboard for each stream they create
and how fast the steam is doing what are
the sinks doing
are they healthy we even have alerts
based on
if there are issues with lags so you
could have a
bad expat filter or json path filter
that you specified
and it's taking too much of cpu
processing and then you start falling
behind
because your source is producing a lot
more data
and so we have alerts on that to notify
that there's lags
and we can identify problems faster
so this is how it looks like currently
um
we have a set of fronting kafka clusters
and the reason we've separated the
fronting and the consumer kafka clusters
for isolation and availability
the fan art is pretty high for some of
the topics so if you were to
leave it on the same cluster it would
impact our
cluster availability
so we have something called kafka kong
we do this every week
we intentionally move traffic from one
cluster to the other
uh we built this automation when we went
live first and you do a bug in zookeeper
and kafka
we had an outage and our larger clusters
that were beyond hundred
nodes didn't recover at all so this lets
us do a quick failover to a new cluster
without
losing much data and we've done it
several times in production since then
it's been a year so we've done it at
least 30 40 times
intentionally and one or two times
unintentionally
so this is how it looks like we have
events flowing through our pipeline
a fronting kafka cluster goes down
okay and we replace it
and it's fully automated so this is how
the
event flows through and
we run it on docker containers we have
our own runtime
and we use mysql we don't have
we don't have any mesos or yarn we just
kept it simple we're going to be moving
into that
so what we're doing now in our in our
next challenge is actually be able to
allow users to specify custom code
and we are choosing flink for it because
of the reasons i mentioned earlier
better state management better tooling
for
reasoning about time and
we're going to look at beam later right
now we want to make sure flink's running
in production and it's very scalable and
stable
so we are we looked at the router use
case now this is how it gets deployed
onto our titus runtime execution
environment
there's a nice talk on qcon if you want
to look at how our runtime is actually
built
there's a separate team that builds this
runtime and we're going to move through
this
here's a job they deployed and
i'll show you an interesting part of it
oops i think it's stuck
okay so we when we did performance
metrics we found that
the flinx side of it is saves us about
17 percent of cost compared to samsa
about 40 better cpu utilization 20
better network utilization
so that's our initial numbers that we
got for a specific use case you may not
be able to reproduce because your use
case might be different your deployment
might be different
and you may not be running in the same
cloud sorry for going over but i'll be
in the
netflix booth on third floor so grab me
if you have more questions you want to
chat more
you